it was all about going as fast you can
because the guy behind you was gonna put
you in jail
that was a demon and how much would you
get to haul a load of liquor to
Greensboro winston-salem back in the
fifties you'd probably make $150 a trip
yeah one night $150 is it not easy to
see how these young guys did that to
haul moonshine you'd need to work late
nights sometimes till the Sun came up
above all you'd need a fast car one that
could handle sharp turns while carrying
a heavy load of illegal liquor about a
decade after prohibition the 1940 Ford
with its hundred horsepower flathead v8
engine was the moonshine haulers car of
choice got to be that you can tell a
bootlegger by the modifications to his
40 Ford I think a Saturday night North
Wilkesboro 1957 wasn't always 40 Ford's
go down the street with the back end
jacked up and you saw that same car
Saturday night about midnight and it was
level that means you had a load on a
load of illegal whiskey the revenuers
are lawmen out to catch him retaliated
with faster cars but the moonshiners
stayed a lap ahead with devious
modifications they installed switches in
the dashboard to turn off the taillights
throwing off whoever was on their tail
bootleggers swapped license plates to
change their identity and underneath the
hood they installed extra carburetors
which jack up the engines capacity to
burn fuel and pretty soon that was
enough they had to go to different
engines they started putting those
Cadillac
emmalin's engines in the 40 Ford trying
to get all the horsepower
but the ultimate secret weapon to halt
and shine was the driver when the Sun
went down the battle was on out foxing
the law turned these drivers into folk
heroes and nuns more legendary than this
man Junior Johnson
when did you how are you starting over
to you 14 so you don't have a license no
then me one more stop good boy you can
afford to stop good enough then the one
that rice or you went to jail I'm doing
loser on the road this quiet country boy
turns into a speed demon unleashed his
tactics are simple outrun the police and
if that doesn't work scare the living
daylights out of them by racing toward
him head-on they didn't want to get
killed I don't think over kids on a
bootleg
I thought us too good a girl get you I
heard him a lot of threats I'm gonna
catch that damned rascal all these time
but it's not just the law bragging among
bootleggers grows heated who has the
fastest car and the skills behind the
wheel